hey everybody Sean McGinnis here along
with Ted price from insomniac games
we're checking out lap checking out a
little bit of new content from sunset
overdrive Ted give us a little bit of
context here what's going on so we're
playing Knight defense which is a part
of chaos squad in the game this is our
multiplayer mode and Knight defense is
the culmination of chaos pod in the game
players get together with seven of their
friends and begin playing through
missions in the open world these
missions can be a randomized and as
you're playing Goutham you get to vote
as a team on what you're gonna do next
and each of these missions offered
something different whether it's combat
traversal challenges even scavenger
hunts in the game but at the very end of
your missions you end up in Knight
defense and in Knight the events you're
defending bats of over charge against
marauding enemies and you've got to work
together to try to keep the od'd from
overrunning this area so how does the
you know the core action compared with
the single-player because obviously what
we've seen of sunset overdrive suggests
a game that's very freeform and
open-ended a lot of crazy chaotic
weapons how does that transition over
here
I transferred translates perfectly I
guess I mean you're basically anything
you earn in campaign comes right over
into your multiplayer anything you win
or earn in multiplayer
goes back to campaign so this basically
is seamless experience one of the great
things about chaos pod though is at the
end of night defense if you're
successful you actually see a bunch of
slot machine slot machine Heights
winners where you can earn new weapons
you can
vanity you can earn new amps which are
the power-ups in our game Pratt -
power-ups and you can earn cash and a
bunch of other things
those you can also bring over into the
campaign just layered into the overall
game is this something that's available
from the beginning is it something that
you kind of have to progress into once
you come to grips with the rest of the
game there are photo booths throughout
the single-player campaign that you can
step into and begin a chaos squad
mission around and that's you never have
to leave to go to a lobby which is
pretty nice cool let's let's narrate a
little bit of how James is doing right
now James is just what James is just
done is lay down a trap so one of the
aspects of night defense that's
important is that you get access to
traps that you have earned in the
single-player campaign you can use those
traps to help delay the swarms of over
od'd overcharged delirium drinkers from
taking your overcharged there are a
whole variety there like of traps
there's a there's one of our plane traps
right there James trunked on it and it
creates these giant gals aflame which
will shoot the overgrow deed up into the
air you probably saw earlier one of our
machete traps this does what it looks
like it does slices enemies into bits
we've got spring traps we've got
rocket traps and it that's what I favor
right there you saw this sort of pop up
jack-in-the-box rocket trap super
effective but James also getting points
whenever his traps take out enemies at
the same time he and his buddies have to
work together to try to hold off these
out over od'd who are making it through
the barriers over here now they're in
their second round of this night defense
and what we're seeing here is a blowers
these are OD to shoot pus there are OD
who mutated around leaf blowers and
they're shooting this organically
creative pus from inside their bodies
and it's dangerous of course but now
we've got more swarms of beso D coming
in one of the things about the od'd is
that they drink too much overcharge they
changed turn into poppers who are even
faster and a lot more dangerous in terms
of the area of effects that they have
when they blow up so they're doing
pretty well they've got ten seconds
until this wave ends and then the chaos
really begins now one day James is doing
that's important is he's grinding
throughout this game you can grind
bounce vaults somersault throughout this
giant city and one of the benefits of
grinding and staying above the fray is
that you're a little bit safer also
gives you a much better vantage point on
the enemies but the weapons are designed
to be used while moving quickly and
using this hyper agility in the world
okay so now we are a final wave we're
probably going to start to see some
hookers these are some of our larger
there's one right there with some more
large enemies if he's if James leaves
them alone he will eventually break
through the barriers and start to make a
path for the smaller Odede
but he can also do is put od'd on his
shoulders
and throw them into the base over the
barriers also what James is doing is
he's cycling through a wide variety of
weapons in the game he just had the t TN
teddy which is one of my favorites now
he's using the propane launcher which is
a propane tank attached to a gas
canister fired at high velocity and now
he's got a K which is probably our most
standard weapon in the game the rest of
the weapons are all really really
different but what makes what makes even
a standard weapon like the ak-47
is that you can attach amps to them amps
in this game are crafted power-ups that
and there are a lot of them you can
attach them to your weapons to your hero
as well for example he just he's got a
health amp which will activate whenever
he slams the ground but amps are act
amps become active when you build up
style and if you notice in the top hat
right hand side of the screen there is a
style meter he's that style level 1 at
this point it's just his melee amps that
are active but he as he starts going to
style level 2 his weapon amps become
active style level 3 he's gonna have be
able to begin to trigger some epic amps
it looks like he's got a hooker in the
base over here to the right you better
take him out because that hurts gonna
break down that barrier and all of a
sudden there's another channel into the
overcharge and look he's got it okay the
hookers got some od'd on top of them now
he's unless James
if James lets up he'll start throwing
the guys into the base but you know what
hookers are a big target so when
everybody sees them they start firing at
them in a scenario like this are there
any systems in place to actively
encourage teamwork or is it more just
about that simple pure reward of staying
alive well if if first of all if
somebody dies you start to lose over
charge and that's that's a big penalty
for the team and if when you lose all
your overcharged it's a bail so you
definitely work together if you want to
earn those great rewards at the end of
the realm but earlier in in some of the
missions that you're going on in the
open world together previous tonight
defense there are many many missions
that require cooperative play but at the
end here what you'll see is a
leaderboard as well so we also have
cooperative competitive elements
the co-operative knows so competitive
essentially you also see these fireworks
going off that's I think the result of
it
let's roll at the dragon pistol the
James is firing or one of his teammates
aspiring actually James has the vinyl
launcher right there which fires records
and when you upgrade that gun and starts
firing gold records which is I think
it's label
it's one of those games where there's
always so much going on in the screen
how do you keep it manageable for when
you have so many players well we we
actually train the players in terms of
how to how to handle this and it helps
when you are beginning to campaign you
start we teach you how to grind we need
to balance we've got to make it through
the world with the guillotine we teach
you what styles all about we teach you
about crafting amps entails teach you
about the weapons and then when you are
jumping in the chaos bar for the first
time we don't start to a night defense
we start you with a mission that may be
a little bit easier to handle but then
you build up your skills and eventually
you can take on something like that
defense it seems like they're still
doing pretty well right what's that
they're still doing pretty well great
they got 37 seconds left they've kept to
their overt charge intact this is a
group of I'd say pretty darn good
players I think James is our ringer here
James is rocking it James is keeping an
eye on the hookers even though it while
the her coaches like bypassed him the
hookers are actually subjective little
fire stuff you use a flaming compensator
which is flaming shotgun it does a lot
more damage than the other weapons and
that's important too you got to know
what the enemy's weaknesses are to us
use your weapons strategically but then
see what's going on we got the our
overcharged bats are under attack now
you get more points actually if you
defend them
if you're defending the overcharge bad
so more points for more kills but
they've only got looks like they would
actually they had no more seconds and
James benders approach so you're right
he's a ringer
17 thousand points kicks my ass when it
comes to score
alright said thanks a lot for your time
I really appreciate it can you go ahead
and remind folks out there when sunset
overdrive is coming out sunset overdrive
is releasing October 28th exclusively on
Xbox one [ __ ] thank you